tony stark is a boss he's so great that
even his biggest mistakes are actually
kind of awesome so why is his showdown
against the fake mandarin one of his
most underrated moments keep watching to
find out
during the final battle between tony
stark the iron man and obadiah stain the
iron monger stained suit is larger and
seemingly more powerful but when the
combatants take to the skies it becomes
clear that stark has thought of
something that obadiah didn't the icing
problem earlier in 2008's iron man stark
tests out the flight systems of the mark
ii suit for the first time and discovers
that flying too high causes the armor to
freeze over and shut down he promptly
fixes this for the mark iii and uses
that to his advantage against iron
monger but this moment is indicative of
one of the best through lines in the
entire mcu the iron man armor doesn't
just change over time tony stark adapts
it from movie to movie based on the
specific events of the previous film in
iron man 2 his suit struggles against
vanco's electrical whips but by the time
of avengers his armor can absorb excess
electricity like it does when hit by
thor's lightning in infinity war stark's
incredible nanotech armor is destroyed
by thanos because in part the collapse
of the suit's physical shields uses up
the armor's limited store of
nanoparticles by end game however tony
has implemented hard light style energy
shields to keep that from happening
again seeing tony's armor adapt to the
specific challenges within each film's
narrative created an incredibly
satisfying technological evolutionary
process and that all started here
at the end of 2008's iron man tony tells
the world that he's the pilot and
inventor of the revolutionary new iron
man armor and by the time its sequel
rolls around in 2010 financial and
political powers the world over want
that tech for themselves to that end
united states senator stern of
pennsylvania leads hearings in which the
man tries to force stark to hand over
the armor to the federal government you
want my property you can't have it but i
did you a big favor
i have successfully privatized world
peace
thank you mr stark thank you buddy
by the end however after iron man and
war machine defeat whiplash and save the
day the u.s decides to award the pair
medals for their service tony asks
shield director nick fury to force
senator stern to eat his words present
the awards himself and personally
congratulate each of them it's a great
scene that's made even richer after
watching captain america the winter
soldier and realizing that cern was a
corrupt member of hydra all along
2012's the avengers has one of the most
fondly remembered after credit scenes of
the entire marvel cinematic universe
after delivering a nuclear missile
through a portal and being caught and
revived by the hulk tony asks the team
they want to get some grub have you ever
tried shwarma
there's a shawarma joint about two
blocks from here i don't know what it is
but i want to try it
after the credits roll audiences are
treated to the avengers eating at that
very restaurant not only is it an
unexpected payoff to a seemingly
throwaway line but it's a great scene
what many fans may not realize however
is that the post-credits scene was set
up earlier after flying inside of a
chittari leviathan jonas style and
blowing it up from the inside he crashes
to the ground right next to the shawarma
joint before rejoining the flight it's
an incredibly easy to miss detail and
one of the best easter eggs in the film
it may not have been what fans expected
but when iron man 3 depicted tony stark
struggling with symptoms of
post-traumatic stress disorder iron man
became one of the most grounded and
human characters in the entire mcu after
nearly dying multiple times in the
battle for the fate of the entire planet
tony doesn't just walk away by having
tony deal with these very human mental
health consequences of the trauma he
experienced iron man simultaneously
became both a better character and a
representative of everybody in the real
world confronting these issues as
clinical psychologist and marvel fan dr
andrea ledamendi wrote tony's struggle
with anxiety is poignant because it
allows us to realize that he is in fact
still human to this end it doesn't
matter to me if his panic attacks are
indicative of clinical ptsd complex ptsd
subclinical anxiety disorder or another
psychiatric category we can use as a
label the point is this a brilliant
powerful and tough guy can be vulnerable
scared and confused
iron man 3 devotes most of its run time
to showing that it's tony stark's
character not his armor that makes him a
hero he's iron man regardless of what
tools or weapons he has at his disposal
and one extended action sequence in
particular demonstrates that idea in
action beautifully cut off from his
friends and normal equipment stark
visits a generic retail store and
creates new weapons out of the everyday
items he can find there armed with only
this his training and his wits he
successfully breaches the defenses of
the mansion allegedly belonging to the
mandarin taking out its guards with his
jury rigged gear just like when he finds
himself imprisoned by the 10 rings in
the original iron man tony stark becomes
iron man by creating the best tools he
has out of the technology around him
though these results may not be as
flashy as his classic armor they are
just as meaningful
when tony stark has jarvis enact the
clean slate protocol and destroy his
entire armory of suits at the end of
iron man 3 many viewers were not happy
it's a controversial moment in an
equally divisive film but it manages to
perfectly capture the movie's themes in
a way that's often overlooked the
majority of the film revolves around
showing not telling that tony stark is
iron man not his armor and this is the
scene that drives that home tony was
coping with the trauma he experienced in
new york in part by overly relying on
his suits of armor those armors
represented that unhealthy and
destructive obsession and obliterating
them was a determined symbol of his
recommitment to being present in both
his own and pepper's lives
by the time 2016's captain america civil
war split the avengers apart tony stark
and pepper potts were taking a break
when steve asks about the couple during
the film tony explains
a few years ago i almost lost her so i
trashed all my suits
then we had to mop up hydra and then
ultron my fault
and then and then and then i never
stopped
the line is an incredible piece of
dialogue that easily and concisely
tracks tony's personal journey from iron
man 3 to civil war and there are a lot
of interesting details that can be
inferred from this for example if this
timeline is taken literally tony didn't
make another iron man suit until after
the events of captain america the winter
soldier this would explain where he was
during the events of the film and could
mean that the helicarriers crashing into
washington dc's potomac river are what
spurred him to put the armor back on
additionally civil war shows that
putting the armor on again in avengers
age of ultron impacted his relationship
with pepper by damaging the gesture he
made with the clean slate protocol
tony's talk with steve is an excellent
recap of how tony got to where he is in
this movie and it's the perfect setup
for the exploration of his motivations
that follow immediately afterwards
fans around the world were thrilled when
sony and disney reached a deal that
finally allowed spider-man to join the
marvel cinematic universe and the wall
crawlers films have been wildly
successful that being said there is one
aspect of the adaptation that has proven
mildly divisive peter's almost sidekick
relationship to tony stark critics
bemoaned the idea that a character who
may just be the most popular and
successful superhero in history was made
into iron man jr the end of spider-man
homecoming however is one moment that
avoids that idea while still utilizing
their mentor relationship in a way that
doesn't diminish either character but
instead builds them both up as their own
heroes having finally beaten the vulture
tony is ready to introduce spider-man to
the world as the newest member of the
avengers but peter says no i'd rather
just stay on the ground for a little
while friendly neighborhood spider-man
somebody's gotta look out for the little
guy right
tony is impressed by peter's maturity
but he also assumed peter would say yes
so he had already announced organized
and started the press conference and now
the reason for it just left to go back
to queens it's a great moment that
highlights peter's development while
also generating some great humor at
tony's expense what am i going to tell
them think of something
how about um
pat you still got that ring do i i think
are you kidding i've been carrying this
since 2008. after stowing away aboard a
ship and sucking ebony maw out into the
vacuum of space tony stark and dr
strange debate what to do next during
their argument tony tells strange thanos
has been inside my head for six years
since he sent an army to new york and
now he's back
that one sentence illustrates a key
through line of tony's journey since the
original avengers film after seeing what
was out there during the battle for new
york tony became haunted by what else
could be out there it was that fear that
drove him to dream of the suit of armor
around the world that unintentionally
resulted in the creation of ultron and
vision in avengers age of ultron it was
this dread that led to his decision in
captain america's civil war to choose
the security of keeping the avengers
together over the freedom of being able
to act as they choose after new york
tony knew three things the aliens had
come from somewhere somebody had sent
them and both were still out there fully
capable of returning this knowledge
influenced tony's actions in every
single film and that's encapsulated
perfectly by this moment
when they first met in 2012's the
avengers tony and steve didn't like each
other one bit but after fighting for
humanity together side by side they
developed a strong friendship that was
ultimately shattered by the events of
captain america civil war unwilling to
compromise and unable to talk things out
the two nearly killed one another before
going their separate ways after thanos
victory at the end of infinity war that
rift seemed wider than ever as tony
seemed to blame steve for their loss
however once an opportunity to restore
everything they'd lost finally appeared
the two put their differences aside and
worked together to gather the infinity
stones from across time and undo the
snap that killed half the universe that
entire personal journey comes to a head
in a singular moment from avengers end
game unable to retrieve the tesseract
and lacking the pym particles to try
again and still make it home the pair's
quest seems over until tony realizes
they can find both in the 1970s during
the early days of shield at camp lehigh
if stark's wrong everybody loses and
they'll become lost in time with
literally half the universe riding on
this one chance tony looks at steve and
asks
you trust me
i do
with that the pair's friendship is
finally fully restored the rift that was
created during civil war is mended and
they are finally facing the end of the
world united
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite heroes are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one